- Hello everyone.
Welcome, good afternoon.
Hope everybody was able
to have like a good lunch
and be able to enjoy.
Hope I don't make you too
sleepy in this session here, okay.
One of the interesting
things just to break the ice
and get everybody like a
little bit more engaged,
who's here is the first time
or like maybe less than three times in the
re:Invent or first time?
Wow, quite a bit of people here.
That is amazing.
Who is maybe more than
10 times in re:Invent?
Nobody, really?
Why I'm asking this, is because actually
a customer asked me yesterday
and I was starting reflecting
and this is my 12th time
in re:Invent, right?
I remember when Trend
came from the first time,
and the re:Invent was the
first cybersecurity vendor.
Being participating in the re:Invent
and being like, seeing the evolution
how much like effort and like everything
that is being built in the re:Invent
is super like impressive.
Thank you for helping me to understand
if it's your first time or not,
but today we are going to
dive into the reality of like
how like AI, it is
becoming one of the most
innovative environments
and most innovative
like driving for organizations,
but at the same time
how AI is transforming
and becoming the new
battleground for attackers.
Like how they are taking an advantage
on this new era, right?
As we are evolving,
creating more AI
infrastructure applications,
utilizing the cloud native services,
how is your new strategy for
protecting those environments?
That is one of the most important
things that we wanted to discuss today.
And when we go here,
starting thinking about like
this is your mission briefing
for a modern AI security
and how you can start strategizing
AI in a different way.
A lot of people sometimes they think no,
AI is just like adding the (indistinct)
or just like using the model
safety in the AI application
and it's actually not true.
There's multiple layers that you can
think about protecting when you are
building those AI applications.
When you think about like
this new battlefield, right,
AI is accelerating innovation
but at the same time it's
expanding the attack surface, right?
More like environments are being using AI,
at the same time you are expanding
how attackers can take advantage
or getting in, in your infrastructure.
Every new AI like a workload
that you're building,
becomes a new vector for attackers
if you don't take the
protection layer needed, right?
Modern security, it is
about embracing innovation
while like you are staying
ahead of like this adversaries
and who is like basically trying
to find different approach
and different ways to get
in, in your environment.
The new battleground, it is
not just about infrastructure.
For many, many years we think
about the cloud infrastructure,
but now it's about the data, the models,
the AI pipelines, all that
combination right now.
It is really important for the life cycle
when you are building the AI applications.
And if you don't think
in a new approach of like
how you're protecting, any new like
attack vector that you create
in one of those points here
are very high valuable.
Why is that?
Because once you affect
one of the infrastructure,
it can affect the entire
ecosystem of your AI application.
Okay, and we are going to
like, in the deeper details
of like how attackers can be manipulating
those AI applications and
taking advantage of that.
When you think about like how adversaries
are exploiting AI applications,
you can think like as a simple flywheel.
The data, the models, AI
pipelines, and run time.
Attackers treat your AI
as their weapon, right?
Poisoning data, stealing models,
and invading run time
or manipulating inputs.
AI is super powerful but that
power also can be hijacked
and be utilized for like bad
actors for stealing your data,
doing data breach of your information,
stealing your intellectual property
that your organization have been spending
so much time and so
much money investing on.
The important thing here
too in this flywheel,
it is your user.
And when I talk about your user,
there's two major points.
User, it is the user that you are
having from your enterprise,
your employees utilizing AI.
Like everybody here, right,
Is using in a way generative AI
for like Chat GPT, Gemini,
some kind of like Bedrock applications
that you created for your customers.
Like there is some level
of like generative AI
being used in the applications.
How you are monitoring any
risks related with those users,
that is important.
The second part of the users,
it is when you build those AI applications
there is like multiple users
that you don't have control.
You don't know if they
are malicious or not.
How you are making sure
every single prompt
that they're interacting with
your AI application are safety.
And how you also, sometimes
these specific prompts
are not like direct attacks.
They're not a prompt
injection that we call.
They're indirect attacks.
What that means, it is, okay,
when you request your AI application
that maybe will search in a
different like search data
that will have like a cross site scripting
that was created by attacker
and when processed by your AI application
it will create a data breach.
People don't think about that
but the input and the output
needs to be validated always
as a additional layer protection, okay?
That's why users critical in this main
like flywheel here when
you were talking about it.
Data poisoning, right?
A lot of people talk about data poisoning
and it's one of the most damaging attacks.
By injecting bad data into training sets
or fine tuning process,
this can manipulate how
your models are going to act
or basically creating the response
for your users, like
employees as I mentioned,
and your user as a
customers as one example.
Making sure every single data
that you are using in the data sets
are being like safe and they don't have
like any kind of like malicious content.
It is critical for every single
AI models that you're training
but also the database vector
that you are creating, okay?
Model theft.
This is important because
a lot of people forget
that like models can be
actually stolen in some cases
and redeployed in infrastructure.
One interesting thing
about like this session,
it is the name of this
session was based actually
in a thread research
that was made by one of
the Trend Micro Thread Research,
Alfredo Oliveira and David Fisher.
They find out like,
that like specifically models can be
utilized as a way for you to export
the model from containers.
Manipulated the way how
they were being trained
and redeployed again to the container,
and the application,
it is actually changing
the outcome of the responses, right?
That's why when you
think about model theft,
it is not just like about manipulating,
but also attackers right now,
they're trying to get your models
to resold in the actual bad market, right?
It's intellectual property.
A lot of customers here,
they not just use the regular data
but also sensitive data as
part of the training, okay?
They're kind of like what we call
the new crown jewels for
organizations, right?
AI pipelines, there's multiple
points in the AI pipelines.
There is like the poisoning that can be
in the model build when you are adding
or you when you are
creating that pipeline,
there is the inject back doors
that can happen through the supply chains
from like open source libraries
that you maybe you'll be using,
or maybe for like affecting
developer machines
that are interacting and adding
back doors to your applications.
There is a way to manipulate
and alter the outputs
from those applications.
Prompting injection for sure
and inference attacks are the most
common for like exploitation.
And shadow AIs are becoming
one of the biggest problems.
And when I say about shadow AI, it is,
do you have a full visibility
of like all the AIs that your
organizations are using today?
A lot of companies they don't, right?
And it's complex because
every single person,
every single developer,
every single cloud architect,
in some ways they are
using different tools.
And having that full visibility
for like everything that
is like AI technologies,
it is important for you
to minimize that shadow AI
problems that you may have
in your organization, okay?
I don't know if you saw
or you're monitoring a lot of Reddit.
Who reads Reddit here?
Okay, half of the room.
That's good.
I was reading this one and catch my eye
and said like I need to use this
in my slides this week, right?
This was like an organization
that was sharing their challenge
about like why they fail an AI project.
And I love and highlighted
this specific spot here
where they're saying,
"Our mistake was relying
on model safety alone
and not like in runtime guardrails."
Why highlight about this?
Because model safety,
it was created for one specific outcome,
for every single model.
And every single model has your
own way to do model safety.
But every single organization
they have your own guardrails
that they should be
created on top of that.
You are not just going to be trusting
in the model safety from like
every single model that there is outside,
because you have no
validation in a lot of cases.
There is some, specifically companies
that do the testings and all of that,
but having your own
guardrails that you can,
making sure which kind
of protection you have
for every single AI agent,
agentic architecture in AI applications,
it is extremely important, okay?
Please, making sure you have that.
Don't get the same mistake.
Why did I bring about this?
Because I think sharing, it is important.
Bringing that as a highlight
for people to remember
when they are building that,
it is extremely important for all of us.
Traditional defenses are very reactive.
We know of this, right?
For many, many years we have been using
specific technologies
that are being the same
for like protecting workloads,
protecting serverless,
or protecting like
containers in some cases.
AI threats evolve too quickly.
Like what was AI six months ago,
it is completely different than right now.
Model drifts, pipeline updates constantly,
agents making a huge amount
of like automation decisions
more and more with agentic approach.
It is extremely important for us
to starting rethinking not in like
a static approach of protection
but in a more proactive approach of like
how we are protecting our
own agentic infrastructure
in AI applications, okay?
You need to be adaptive,
you need to be proactive,
and you need to have some
kind of like AI awareness
that the AI can learn through the process
and understand your risk prioritization
for you to mitigate it soon as possible
before going into production.
I created like a little
lineup of like this session
with like the different layers
that we should be reflecting about, right?
And let's begin at the
foundation here, data.
Most AI risks originated
actually in the data, right?
AI systems often process
massive amounts of data
and any blind spots how
to data can be stored,
shared, and classify becomes
a direct attack vector
for like specific attacks.
This visibility here, it
is a portion of your data
that is considered classified data, right?
You know what is that data,
you know the information usually,
but that's like just a surface, right?
Majority of the data that we actually have
are under like that surface,
or like unknown data are unclassified,
are like unprotected data
that a lot of times
people forget about that.
They use as part of the training,
they use as the database factory,
they use as the defined creation
for your AI applications,
but they actually forgot
to check and validate it
if there is any sensitive information
before the actual utilization of that.
And this is where things can
be a little bit tricky here.
Like understanding that data
and understanding if they're sensitive.
And you can, for sure you can
use for your AI applications
but now, okay, my AI
application is utilizing
one specific set of like
sensitive information.
The level of protection
on that application
needs to be way higher because the risk
of data exfiltration is extremely high
and risky for the organization, okay?
When you talk about data
leakage, it can happen anywhere.
During training, inference logs,
through APIs communication,
even through models outputs, right?
The interaction that you
have with the models.
Attacks exploits this weak points
to extract any kind of like sensitive
information that they may find.
PII data, information about passports,
people, emails, account
information, and so on.
Depending the level of like
what is your organization
providing outside, right?
And they can do some level of like
reverse engineering depending
on the information that they get.
Our response here and the way how you
should be thinking, it is like
how can you create a data posture
security management, right?
How you can start in monitoring
every single data set
before the actual training,
before the actual utilization
by your AI applications
and understanding which
ones are sensitive,
which ones have like intellectual property
from your organization,
and which ones are like
actually no problem, right?
It's a public information
that can be utilized
and if you have any attack
on this application,
even it's like compromising the
image from your organization,
they're not compromising the data
that is the most important
and the crowd use for a lot of companies.
Okay, the next one.
We move to the stack up and we
talk about like AI microservices
like supply chains.
AI components depend on like countless
number of like libraries.
Open source applications
that is being utilized outside containers
and external services, right?
Each of like has an indirect way
for infiltration by attackers, right?
More and more we see supply chain attacks
in the organizations.
And that's why it's
really, really important
for all of us to make sure,
because a single vulnerability,
a single dependency
shoe in your application
can be a domino effect,
can be starting affecting
the entire application
and the way how you were
building the security strategy
for that like environment or workload.
When a new component is compromised,
the entire life cycle will be affected.
And not just like the runtime
but also any new application
that is being utilizing the foundation
that's used for other applications, right?
That's why it's important to
have a continuously monitoring
for any vulnerability in the pipeline,
in the supply chain,
secrets that can be forgotten
inside the container image,
mowers that can be embedded
by attackers, and so on.
And when you talk about
like attack vectors, right,
there's three major ones
that I actually got here.
Dependency poisoning,
this is probably one of the most common
when you are using a lot of
the open source libraries
and if you are not validating those.
Unverified image, that is very,
very important for all of us.
I know we talk about
shift to lab security,
we talk about container image scanning,
it's still a lot of companies missing that
basic or foundation layer protection.
Very, very important for
all of you to make sure.
And when we talk about like
it's not just looking for vulnerabilities
but also looking for secrets.
Recently we have been
finding more and more
container image that are public facing
that in some ways, there is a way for you
to access secrets inside
the container image
that can compromise your
cloud infrastructure.
This could be AWS credentials,
it could be applications credentials
that are like plain text,
forgotten inside actual containers, right?
Really important for you to
make sure you are validating
and verifying and maybe
creating like a signature
for every single image.
This way if there is any kind of
like a compromised supply chain,
the image needs to be validated by your
security controls that you have it.
And pipeline compromise, right?
Adversary is trying to affect the systems,
not just like the regular from like
a coder post storage to the CI/CD pipeline
but from the developer machines.
More attacks are being
affected the developers
that can drive malicious code
to the actual supply chain
that needs to be validated.
When you talk about this,
we are talking about like
CI/CD pipeline verification,
we are talking about container
and code integrity checking
for vulnerabilities, secrets,
mowers, misconfiguration,
and all that information being part
of like your application visibility.
Whatever you deploy in production,
how can you have a full
visibility from the shift to left
to the run time, okay?
Model and AI agents,
and when like things can
go like rogue, right?
Models and agents can be,
can become like attack vector themselves.
Once they are compromised,
they can basically
interact with your systems
and affect in the way how
they are being manipulated
or getting information that
can be exfiltrated outside.
And can be basically affecting data
and be harmful for the
infrastructure that you build, right?
Models can be poisoning,
manipulated, or misled through
subtle adversaries, right, inputs.
AI agents which can act autonomously
introduce the entire
new class of like risks
that can affect the entire infrastructure
when you are building
the agentic approach.
When you're talking about
like agentic approach,
if you have an AI agent that is going
outside their like scope, right,
this is actually interesting conversation
because yesterday I was talking with like
one of the biggest software
organizations in the globe.
And one of the biggest challenges
that they're facing right now,
they are creating more and more agents
as part of their agentic approach
but they don't have a way to
control the scope of the agent.
If the agent is starting acting in
a different approach as they created,
they don't have a way to remediate it.
They don't have a way to mitigate and like
contain that agent,
should not affect other parts
of the infrastructure, okay?
That's really, really important
and it's very associated with
the unauthorized actions on those agents.
Key attacks vectors includes
malicious inputs here,
woke agent behavior, manipulate outputs.
Attacks try to steer the models
into unsafe actions, right?
Or bypass the safety components.
That's why I was talking
about like the model safety.
Every attacker have access to your models
that is like open source
and they understand really, really well
how the model safety works in each model.
But the guard rails that you created,
they are customized for you.
You understand the challenge
and the risks in your AI applications.
That's why it's important for
you to edit on that, right?
And when you talk about
like the guardrails,
there is two layers here.
Because model, it is very dedicated
and mathematical way to decision.
Like you can ask the same question
100 times to the models,
the answers and outputs in
some cases will be different.
You all tested this already, right?
The point here is
when you are testing securing the models,
you cannot test just once.
You need to keep like
continuously testing the models
to make sure maybe that
attack that didn't work today,
maybe it'll work tomorrow
because you changed something.
You're retraining with
like a different dataset
and the actual decision making
of the model are changing
and give information that
they should not, right?
That is why it's really very
important for you to make sure
that interaction and
continuously validation
when you are building those applications.
And one of the interesting
things that we did this week,
it is a launching of like a new
tag that we call AI Scanner.
What that means, it is, okay,
you can point it out, AI
application, the API endpoint,
we are going to scan that AI application
for sensitive data disclosure,
for prompt injections,
system prompt leakage,
malicious code generation,
agent two definitions leakage,
and many other things associated with the
OWASP top 10 for LLMs and generative AI.
Those informations and those risks
are being utilized by our
systems in the backend,
what we call LLM judge.
Our LLM judge, it is embedded
as part of the guardrails.
This way, whatever risks we detect there,
it can be automatically protected.
I like to say for people who knows Trend,
this is like the new virtual patching
for AI applications, right?
We have a virtual patching for protective
vulnerabilities for many, many years.
This is a new approach of like
how we are protecting the application,
the AI applications in real time
as we identify those
risks right away, okay?
This basically extends of like how you are
creating a prevention mechanism
for every single OWASP Top 10
being analyzed by your
scanner as one example.
Infrastructure and Under Siege, right?
AI infrastructure, it
is extremely important
and attackers are trying
to take advantage.
It could be because the
resources exhaustions,
it can be by the utilization of the GPUs,
it can be by the cloud
services infrastructure
that they're trying to
take advantage for mining,
or crypto mining for
their own specific gains.
This visual here,
it's a frontline infrastructure, right?
When you think about like
how you're protecting
like your castle of like you when you
are building AI applications, right?
Compute, privilege, access,
access coverage from the
different like AI applications
or containers or microservices.
All that highlights a huge impact
that can affect the AI applications.
But when you think about this,
usually a lot of customers are
concerned about like how attackers
are not being compromised
in my infrastructure
for resources exhaustion,
for increasing the cost
of the GPUs utilization
that happens in some cases
when they have access
to your infrastructure, and
also data leakage, right?
Those are the three most critical things
that I usually hear from customers.
When infrastructure controls are weak,
attackers can hijack
workloads and drain resources
and take advantage of your cloud accounts.
There are companies that went bankrupt
because this kind of like
attacks back in the day, right?
I hope no more, as more people are aware
about the security elements
that they should be adding
for every single account.
But it's really, really
important for all of us
to remember that security needs
to be created from the scratch.
From the moment that you are building
your AI infrastructure, okay?
When you think about like those different
like attack vectors on the infrastructure,
a lot of times are related
with the privilege escalation,
cloud misconfigurations,
and vulnerabilities that can be affected
from outside to inside the organizations.
A lot of them, they're focusing
like a deny of services, right?
Basically stopping your
systems to work, right,
and people won't be able to access.
In a lot of cases also as I mentioned,
the cost increase,
that can create like a massive problem
for some organizations, okay?
Infrastructure it is important
because you need to think about like
the AI security posture management,
how you are monitoring for every
potential misconfiguration
in Bedrock, SageMaker,
or any other infrastructure
that you're using from the cloud provider.
But also how you tie in that
with the new compliances,
like it could be
the EU act from Europe,
it can be like a new
systems from the CSA in US,
it can be from OWASP Top 10
that like it is being very vocal
like how you should be looking
for those risks involving AI applications.
All those elements are tie in
with the AI secure posture management.
The other point, it is AI
models, resources, controls.
When you are having those infrastructures,
they usually generate logs, right?
Majority of the logs are being basically
collected through like a
VPC flow logs in some cases
and the cloud trails.
What we do in these cases,
it is collecting that information
and apply tread intelligence
on top of that, right?
If we see any suspicious activities
happening with like a
SageMaker or Bedrock,
you can basically create
a cloud detection response
to mitigate those
attacks right away, okay?
Network.
As more and more organizations
are building the AI applications
and making that available,
there is a new path,
right, for manipulation.
In the beginning, AI applications was like
basically focused of
like the internal usage.
Now more and more companies
are putting that outside
and it's very, very important
for us to validate it
because in some organizations
they have a hybrid infrastructure.
I was actually right before here
talking with an Israel customer
where they have like a full dedicated
data centers for some of the applications,
but they're also creating some level
of like a cloud infrastructure
and they want to connect with each other.
Hybrid, it is a very common element
for a lot of companies that we see today.
But how they can have the same level
of protection for like
the APIs communications
but also potential vulnerabilities
that can exist on those
infrastructure, okay?
Attackers use vulnerabilities
that are like fighting very often.
One of the things that Trend
tried to help on this way,
it is through what we call
Zero Day Initiative, ZDI, okay?
We are the biggest bug
boundary for enterprise
vulnerabilities in the market, right?
Last year we found 73% of the
total vulnerabilities in the market
and our goal is like how we can bring
that information about the vulnerabilities
in the different like
AI stack applications
for you all be aware of like the issues
and the risks involving
AI technologies, okay?
It can be MF flow, it can be MCP servers,
it can be many different
like parts of the AI stack
that you are using that
sometimes people forget
that potential vulnerabilities can exist.
And part of this, we did
like a recently launch
with AWS on the year, AWS Firewall.
Where we can edit our IDS and IPS rules
on top of the AWS Firewall
for you to protect against those exploits,
those vulnerabilities.
It's additional layer in
clouded like native approach
with AWS to enhance
those network protection.
When you talk about like
network attack vectors, right,
we are talking about
like an API interception
that are very important lateral movements
that can be moving from
one container to another
or from one VPC to another VPC.
Data exfiltration,
when the attackers find
the critical assets
or the critical data they're trying
to exfiltrate it to outside, right?
And having that like layer visibility
or that like layer of like a risk
with like a different network sensor,
it is really important.
Plus the IDS and IPS visibility.
If there is any exploits coming
to your cloud infrastructure,
how do you see that?
How can you not just like detect,
but how you can actually prevent
and block those exploits right away?
Drafting traffic inspection
is really important.
Not just for the regular traffic
but also the APIs that the
people forget about this.
I was checking some data recently
and I was actually super skeptical
and concerned because a lot of customers,
they are forgetting about
adding a layer of like
authentication authorization
in API gateways
and API end points.
40% of the total APIs that
we are monitoring today,
they are not having any level
of like authorization and verification.
This is super concerning.
What that means, it is
if those API endpoints are
connected with critical data,
they have a freedom.
It's kind of like a free highway
to get access to that data.
Please make sure every single
time when you have an API
open to the internet,
they are being validated.
They have some level of authentication
as a minimal layer protection.
Plus if you can,
add like some layer of like IDS and IPS
to protect that too, okay?
Users: The Human Factor,
it's been the biggest problem for probably
since the internet has
been created, right?
Every single organization,
we have that user that can click
and do all the things
that the security teams
or the security awareness
tell them to not do it,
they actually go against, right?
Even if we do the training
awareness and all that.
But how you can make sure the human error
it is not giving like
access to infrastructure?
How do you make sure
every single developer
are aware about like the risks involving
of like things that they're
accessing from outside?
It is super, super important
to understand the access control,
the permissions that the users, they have,
phishing, social engineering attacks
that happens every single day.
Those awareness, it is super important
for people to starting paying
attention what they're doing, right?
More and more scams are being created.
With AI right now, it's been crazy.
Deepfake attacks and more are coming
as a big problem When
you think about human.
One single
click or one single malicious library
can open the door for like the attacker
inside your organization.
That's how critical it is
a human in our companies.
If they do a mistake,
it can be open the door
and if you don't have a validation after,
they'll be able to take advantage
of like going lateral movement,
detecting sensitive information,
and do couple other things that
can compromise your company.
Misconfiguration is a good,
it's a problem sometimes, right?
Overexposed access for specific users
and deepfake manipulation
are increasing heavily.
Mainly like the deepfake for sure
with the usage of like
AI on those technologies.
Having ways that you can
monitoring, for example,
developers today are
creating AI applications
in their own desktops because they're
getting more GPUs and all, and so on.
Having ways that you're
monitoring those AI applications
and making sure attackers
are not manipulating
the configuration file and those
applications are important.
Having, like it's
important for you to have
this kind of layer
protection for local AI apps.
The second one, having a way to detect
and protect against deepfakes.
Okay, that's important.
And phishing attacks for sure.
Every single organization
should have already
because it's increasing
every single day with AI.
Okay, as we wrap up here,
the mission is, I think
it's very clear, right?
We create like a little,
a flow of like coming from
the data to the users.
The last point in every
single organization.
Securing AI requires a
connecting every single layer
from the data to the users
with a full visibility
and proactive controls.
When you think about this,
it is like not just adding
one layer protection,
AI security only works when data, models,
pipelines, and runtime are unified
under a single security lens.
Why do I say this?
It is, sometimes if you have
like a disparate technologies
for data, for AI pipelines, or for models,
the problem in this case it is
you are not correlating those telemetries,
you are not correlating the findings
that can help us to create like
a mitigation detection response.
Super important for all of
you to make sure those points.
As I mentioned this session here
was actually based in one
of the thread research
that we found globally.
It's called, this article was called
"Silent Sabotage: Weaponizing AI Models
in Exposed Containers".
This case, a malicious actor was able
through a exposed container
that was public facing,
extract the model, right?
Get the model, manipulated
the data of the model,
redeploy or kind of
like reimport that model
back to the container
that's being exposed,
and compromising the way the predictions
are being solved, right?
Why I mention about this?
Because there are technologies,
like container secure
technologies in runtime
that you can have this
kind of like monitoring.
Like one of the rules
that I was mentioning here
is like any kind of like
external connectivity with the containers
that are trying to extract files
or that they're trying to
manipulate files in the container.
Container should be mutable, right?
Like should be not changing.
If you are changing, you
should be changing the pipeline
before you push a production, right?
But this is really interesting
article for you all
to see it and understand a little bit more
where this session came from
and why we are talking about
this layers protection here, okay?
One of the interesting
things we talk about,
this approach of like layer protection
came from my actually
last session in re:Invent
where I created what we call
AI security blueprint, okay?
And that AI security blueprint,
we actually not just wanted
to create as a paper,
as an informative information for you,
but we bring that to our platform.
We brought like every
single layer on that one
to the developers, deployment,
runtime, AI workloads,
AI applications, AI data,
and as we identify every single specific
piece of AI infrastructure
in your environment,
we also map it if you have
the layer protection enabled or not.
The idea here is like helping you
to identify if every single
layer protection that we have,
you are being able to protect
and prevent from malicious
actors on that, okay?
When you talk about like
those layers protection,
what I did here for customers
to help, is okay, data.
What are the security challenge?
What are the security controls
that exist in the market?
And how our platform can
help with some technologies.
Microservices, when you're
talking about microservices,
it's not just Kubernetes.
It could be NIMs, NVIDIA NIMs, right?
Where you are creating those containers
that are being utilized
by NVIDIA technologies.
Models, agents, how you are
protecting that interaction
as you are building those AI applications
and retraining those models.
Infrastructure, it could be a AWS
or any other cloud provider plus
any VD infrastructure if
you have some of those.
How you are applying AI
secure posture management,
API risk visibility
for unauthorized risks,
AI detection response as I mentioned,
when you collected those
informations from Bedrock
and SageMaker, you are able
to apply detection models
on top of that to identify
any suspicious activities,
Any AI application
security that I mentioned
about the AI scanner
and the AI guard, okay?
The two ones here,
because I know people were taking photos,
was like the network layer
that's related with
the network IDS and IPS
where we can prevent and protect against
the exploitation when you
have those applications
or those AI stacks, how
we talk that, right?
And the last one is the user,
how you can basically protect on those.
There's a comprehensive paper on this
AI security blueprint that I
go in every single detail here
and explain more information.
So like why you should be
protecting the use cases
and the level of like the layer protection
that you should be thinking when you are
creating those strategies, okay?
Okay, preparing for like the next wave.
AI-born attacks are being
accelerated every single day.
To stay resilient, we
must anticipate a threat.
We need to think in a different way
how we are protecting
against those threats.
Automated defense and
evolve infrastructure
as fast as the adversaries
are evolving their attacks
are extremely important
for us today, okay?
Proactive AI security,
it is something that
you should be thinking
for like this new adaptive
way for you protecting
not just your AI applications
but every single application
that you have in the organization.
The velocity, how we are innovating
in every single company today,
it is unbelievable, right?
We release new applications,
we release new versions
every couple of minutes
in those companies here today.
Okay, we are doing some pretty cool stuff.
I dunno if you saw what we
call a Trend Vision One Vault.
People in the United
States can win $10,000
if they crack the code.
This session is giving one of the codes
for you to have the way to test it
and trying to crack the code.
The number three, it is the number
that I'm giving from the session.
I hope some of you will win, okay.
We're playing this since Black Hat
and nobody was able to crack
and I hope somebody this time in re:Invent
will be able to crack the
code for the $10,000, okay.
Without more, I want to
say thank you so much
for joining me today in this session.
Really appreciated your attention.
And if there is any question,
I'm open because there
is actually time here
that I can answer some of the questions.
But thank you so much, everyone.
Really appreciate it.
(audience applauds)